like a splash of cold water in the face
Aquaman has arrived and though it's
great it's also a little confusing
jammed with a century's worth of
undersea exposition don't worry though
we're here to help you keep track of all
those lost tribes and strange artifacts
so grab your life preserver because
here's a spoiler filled explanation of
the ending of Aquaman Arthur and Mary's
search for the legendary lost Trident of
King at land took them to some exotic
locales but none were more unexpected
than the center of the earth itself but
longtime comic book fans know that if
there's one place you should always
expect the unexpected it's the land of
Skartaris see in the 1970s DC Comics
series the warlord it was revealed that
scar Terrace is a prehistoric jungle
world accessible through portals that
connected to earth and after the
destruction of Atlantis a band of
refugees traveled through one of these
portals to Skartaris and founded new
atlantis though Aquaman didn't run into
any of the citizens of New Atlantis
during his brief time on the other side
of the portal it would make sense that
the final resting place of at land's
Trident was actually scar Terrace as it
would explain the fate of the missing
tribe which opens the door to a whole
new world of adventure quite literally
once Arthur finally got his hands on at
Lin's trident fans got to see an
incredibly confusing sequence where it
seemingly lit up the nervous systems of
a bunch of random sea creatures there
was no concrete explanation as to what
was actually happening
leaving viewers to wonder just what
exactly this mythical Trident actually
does other than spark up what appeared
to be a bonus level from Tetris effect
earlier in the film it said that the
Trident gave Atlin command of the Seas
the prevailing theory is that the
Trident essentially enhanced Aquaman's
natural ability to communicate with sea
life amplifying it to the point where he
could exert his will and actually
control it that would explain how he was
able to command the Curan as well as the
shark mounts used by king ORMs forces it
even seemed to extend to the trench
dwelling Atlantean descendants who had
devolved back into a more monstrous form
you have to hand it to princess Mara not
only did she save Atlantis and the
surface world as well she also managed
to free yourself from an unwanted
political marriage by replacing the
ambitious and scheming prince armed with
the much more suggestible and well kind
of dumber Arthur it was a brilliant
maneuver from the real power behind the
throne
mrs. ad your best thinking when you're
not thinking at all those worst pep talk
ever and Arthur is going to need Maris
political acumen because he's way out of
his depth no pun intended so far it
doesn't seem like he's even heard the
word diplomacy sure a lot was made of
Aquaman's unique ability to bring the
surface world and Atlantis together but
you have to be able to do more than talk
to fish to get that done you have to
talk to people and so far that doesn't
really seem to be his strong suit did
anybody really think Black Manta was
dead just because his head exploded and
he fell hundreds of feet into the angry
ocean bouncing off every single
outcropping of rock in Italy on the way
down of course not
considering the lengths to which
director James Wan went to and ordered
to shoehorn Manta and his original story
into a film that didn't need him there's
no way he was going to be written out
that easily so what can fans expect from
Manta in future Aquaman films well comic
book readers have a pretty good idea and
it ain't pretty way back in the 1970s
Black Manta was at the center of one of
the most shocking storylines in comics
history as he finally got his revenge on
Aquaman by murdering Arthur and Mary's
infant son we're not sure a sequel will
get quite that dark but Aquaman's dad is
still alive and would seem like a ripe
target for mantas vengeance especially
since the mid credit scene showed Manta
teamed up with Atlantis obsessed
researcher Stephen chin in the comics
Shin was a friend of Aquaman's dad who
betrayed them both to satisfy his
compulsion to find the location of
Atlantis so will things play out
similarly in the movies with black manta
and dr. shin working together not to
mention the continued danger of prince
or min the existence of star terrasse
one thing is for sure Aquaman 2 will
have no shortage of plot lines to choose
from besides giving him the ability to
command the creatures of the sea
the Trident of Atlin was also supposed
to serve as the ultimate trump card
granting Arthur the title of king of
Atlantis yet when he showed up with the
Trident to try and stop the Atlantean
Civil War surprisingly few people on
either side of the battle seemed to
actually notice or care at least at
first it's clear that his goal of
uniting the seven tribes of Atlantis is
going to take a whole lot more work than
just raising a lofty underwater
equivalent of xcalibur
as a wise man once said supreme
executive power derives from a mandate
from the masses not from some farcical
aquatic
ceremony becoming King isn't the end of
Arthur's work it's just the beginning
magic Trident or no magic trident
[Music]